today we are going to be making chicken  noodle soup so the first thing you're  going to do is you're going to season  your chicken with everything that I've  listed on the screen and then you're  going to sear it on both sides before  removing it from your pot you're then  going to add onion garlic and celery  along with your chicken back then some  broth and then you're going to let it  cook fully before removing it add celery  carrots more liquid bay leaf herbs and  heavy cream along with your noodles and  your chicken that you've deboned and  then you're going to let it cook Slow  and Low this is the creamiest softest  chicken noodle soup you'll ever have try  it out and let me know what you think